[موسيقى]
اذا الفيديوهات الحكايات والقصص لا تنتهي
ولا تتوقف فلكل جثه يتم انتشالها من تحت
الارض من بين الركام ولكل شخص حي ما زال
عالقا او تمكن من الخروج بفعل عمليات
الانقاذ لكل منهم حكايه حتى هذه اللحظه
حيث قفزت حصيله ضحايا الزلزال لاكثر من 16
الف واربعمائه قتيل في الوقت الذي يعمل
فيه رجال الانقاذ في سباق مع الزمن
لانتشال ناجين محتملين محاصرين تحت انقاذ
الاف المباني التي انهارت بفعل الزلازل
ففي تركيا اعلنت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
ان عدد وفيات الزلزال ارتفع الى
12,873 فيما ذكر المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان ان حصيله ضحايا الزلزال في سوريا
ارتفعت الى
356 قتلا
مع تعثر وصول المساعدات الى سوريا قالت
منظمه القوه البيضاء ان عدد ضحايا الزلزال
سيرتفع بشكل كبير بسبب وجود مئات العائلات
تحت الانقاض مؤكده ان تاخر وصول المساعدات
سيؤدي الى ارتفاع اعداد الضحايا واكدت
المنظمه ان فرقها تواصل عمليات الانقاذ
وسط ظروف صعبه كما كشفت ان عدد الابنيه
المنهاره كليا في شمال غرب سوريا ارتفع
الى 418 فيما تجاوز عدد الابنيه المنهاره
جزئيا حاجز الالف
الى ان الاف المباني الاخرى تصدعت جراء
زلزال
نبقى معكم في هذه التغطيه ومع ضيوف
العربيه وايضا شبكه مراسليها نبدا اولا مع
مراسل العربيه من القامشلي جمعه كاش جمعه
اهلا بك معنا في هذه التغطيه وفي هذه
الساعه الاخباريه الاداره الذاتيه للاكراد
في شمال سوريا كانت اطلقت حمله تبرعات
شعبيه لاغاثه متضرري الزلزال هل من
الاستجابه
نعم نادين يعني منذ حوالي ساعه ونصف من
الان اعلنت الاداره الذاتيه عن حمله من
التبرعات الشعبيه يعني ناشدت فيها الاهالي
وايضا الشركات ورجال الاعمال والقطاع
الخاص بالتبرع بسخاء لهذه الحمله التي
سيصار الى تحويلها اما على شكل اموال
نقديه احب مساعدات انسانيه الى مناطق
المنكوبه في كل السوريه بشقيها المعارضه
والنظام الان لدي معلومات مؤكده بان
القافله الاولى طبعا المساعدات مباشره
القافله الاولى
للمساعدات الانسانيه التي قدمتها الاداره
الذاتيه دخلت من معبر ام الجلود في بلده
منبج باتجاه بلدتي جرابلس اي دخلت الان
الى مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
لكي نسمعها جيدا
نعم يعني المساعدات التي قدمتها الاداره
وعلت عنها تشمل ثلاثه اقسام القسم الاول
حمله تبرعات شعبيه بدات هذه الحمله القسم
الاخر وهو يعني شاحنات محمله بالمواد
الاغاثيه والطبيه هذه الشاحنه
بداياتها بدات تدخل الى مناطق جرابلس يعني
من جلود في منبج في المدينه الواقعه تحت
السيطره الاداره واقوات فسد دخلت القافله
الان الى بلده جرابلس لوصار لتذهب الى
المناطق المنكوبه تحديدا الى ارياف ادلب
وحلب يعني
القافله الانسانيه المقدمه للاداره
الذاتيه دخلت الان الى مناطق
المعارضه طبعا هناك ايضا 100 شاحنه محمله
بالوقود ستدخل الى مدينه حلب على الاغلب
ستذهب الى مناطق الاشرفيه الشيخ مقصود
والمناطق التي تقع تحت سيطره
داخل محل بالنسبه للتبرعات جمعه وقوافل
المساعدات التي اشرت اليها واخرها الشاحنه
المحمله بالمواد التي تدخل منبج الى
جرابلس وتحديدا الى المناطق المنكوبه ثم
بعدها هل يتم الحديث عن معلومات او اي
معلومات وصلتكم حتى هذه اللحظه عما هو
متداول عن وصول حزمه مساعدات المتضرريه
الزلزال في الشمال السوري تاتي من الالوان
المتحده ومن المجتمع الدولي كان متوقع
وصولها اليوم هل من معلومات جديده
نعم يعني كنا قلنا قلنا امس بان هناك عدد
من الدول لديها طائرات وصلت الى مطار غازي
عنتاب وطائرات اخرى وصلت الى مطار اضنه
هذه المساعدات يعني المقدمه من دول عربيه
على راسها السعوديه وايضا قطر هذه
المساعدات من يعني من المفترض ان تدخل
خلال الساعات قريبه في انتظار بعض
الاجراءات الروتينيه والموافقات من الطرف
التركي يوصل الى اتقالها الى هذه المناطق
ايضا كنت قد قلت يوم امس بان الامم
المتحده عبر مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين جهزت
قافله تحمل مساعدات انسانيه وطبيه في
طريقها للدخول عبر معبر باب الهوى هذه
الشحنات جاهزه موجوده في تركيا وتسير
باتجاه معبر باب الهوى وهما اكدته ايضا
وكاله نحن نتحدث عن بضع ساعات ليصار الى
ادخال مساعدات من شقين مساعدات مقدمه من
دول وايضا مساعدات مقدمه من هي الامم
المتحده
هيئه مفوضيه لشؤون اللاجئين وايضا لدى
منظمه الصحه العالميه ايضا شحنه من
المساعدات سوف تدخل الى مناطق شمال غرب
ناديني اذا كان الوقت سيسمح ساتحدث
الواقعه ايضا تحت سيطره النظام المنافذ
الجويه كانت المساعده الطائرات تصل الى
مطار دمشق وحلب اليوم بدات الطائرات تصل
الى مطار اللاذقيه ايضا يعني نحن نتحدث
الان عن تفحيص
مطار حلب مطار اللاذقيه بدات الطائرات
تهبط فيها
دمشق مساعدات من عدد كبير من الدول حتى
الان من الامارات من الجزائر من ليبيا من
سلطنه عمان ايضا من الهند ومن الصين ومن
باكستان ومن ارمينيا كل هذه الدول ارسلت
طائرات تحمل مساعدات انسانيه وطبيه وصلت
الى المطارات الثلاثه التي ذكرتها هذه
المساعدات توزع على
المنكوبين في بلدات في مدن اللاذقيه وادلب
الهدفيه حلب
وطرطوس وجبله وبشكل يعني قليل في مدينه
حماه الاقل تبررا من هذا الزلزال
وبالتاكيد يعني الساعات المقبله والايام
المقبله ستوضح ان كانت فعلا وصلت
المساعدات لكافه المناطق ليس فقط التابعه
للنظام السوري وايضا التابعه لسيطره
المعارضه وحتى ايضا التي تتولى سيطرتها
تركيا سنكون معك جمعه في الساعات المقبله
وان كان اي جديد خلال هذه الساعه بالتاكيد
سنعود اليك ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه نشكرك
جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات من
القامشلي مراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش الذي
افادنا قبل قليل بان شاحنات محمله
بالمواد الغذائيه والمعونات بدات تدخل من
معبر منبج دخلت الى جرابلس وباتجاه الى
المناطق المنكوبه
جديد وهناك ايضا طائرات محمله بالمساعدات
الاغاثيه للمنكوبين وصلت الى ثلاث مطارات
نحن نتحدث عن مطار دمشق حلب واللاذقيه في
الساعات المقبله سنعرف المزيد عن اليه
توزيع هذه المساعدات وفقا لاولويات
المناطق الاكثر تضررا من المناطق الاقل
تضررا حتى هذه الساعه الى هذا الخبر حيث
رصدت كاميرا العربيه تواصل فرق الخوض
البيضاء لعمليات الانقاذ ورفع حطام البيوت
في قريه في ادلب وسط امال اهالي القريه
للعثور على احياء من ذويهم واخراجهم من
تحت الانقاض
يا شباب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بس بس شو بتساوي
الناس في حاله زعر كلها تحت الركام مثل ما
انكم شايفين اجيت هالشباب هاي الموجوده
كلياتها كتفه تتساعدت ولكن بالاياديش يا
حسنيه يعني نحتاج لكادرا اكبر ما حدا قصر
بس هاي امكانيات الشعب الموجود الله يكون
بالعون
جايين جايين تطوع هون
يعني العالم ماسات الله اكبر سنه 48 ساعه
ولسه في عالم تحت الاوقات
حجم الكارثه كبير وفي رقمها تقوم بالبحث
الى الان في قريه بثانيه على اخراج
العالقين تحت الانقاض
نذهب الان الى سرمدا الشمال ادلب معنا من
هناك مدير المصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع
المدني السوري اهلا بك منير معنا في سياق
هذه التغطيه هل توسعت عمليات الانقاذ الى
احياء جديده على وجه الخصوص والى مناطق
جديده على وجه العموم
نعم في الحقيقه يعني منذ الظهر البارحه
استطاعت فرق الخوض البيضاء بالوصول من
الوصول الى كافه المناطق المتضرره
والفرق الان متواجده في كل مناطق يعني لم
يبقى اي منطقه لم تصل لها فرق القوى
البيضاء ولكن المعاناه هي كبيره بسبب عدد
العالقين العالي تحت الانقاذ العوائل
المتواجده هذه النقطه التي اشرت اليها
بانكم وصلتم الى كافه المناطق في الوقت
التي تقول فيه الامم المتحده بين 5% فقط
من المناطق
المنكوبه والتي تضررت بفعل الزلازل تم
الوصول اليها والبدء بعمليه الانقاذ فيها
انا حقيقه اريد ان اوضح هذه النقطه انا لا
اعلم من اين يعني جاء هذا الخبر عند الامم
المتحده فرق الخوذه البيضاء موجوده في
شمال غرب سوريا وهي يعني تصل الى كل
النقاط وليس هناك تواصل مباشر مع فريق
الامم المتحده حتى يتم تح بالمئه واكثر او
اقل انا اؤكد لك ان فرق الخواد البيضاء
وصلت منذ ظهر البارحه بعد ظهيره البارحه
الى كامل النقاط التي فيها انهيارات والان
الفرق هي تعوم بعمليات البحث والانقاذ
وسحب العالقين من تحت الانقراض ولكن للاسف
نحن اشدنا منذ الساعات الاولى بان يتم
تزويد فرق الخوذه البيضاء بمعدات واليات
حتى تساهم بالوصول الاسرع يعني نحن وصلنا
ولكن للاسف اليوم نتحدث عن 75 ساعه من
العمل يعني اول 72 ساعه هي تعتبر ساعات
ذهبيه من اجل انتشار يعني عالقين او سحب
عالقين تحت لانقاضهم على قيد الحياه الان
للاسف عداد الضحايا سوف يزداد يعني نحن
نتكلم عن 1900 قتيل تم انتشاله من تحت
الانقاذ في 72 ساعه الماضيه ولكن سوف
نلاحظ بعد هذه الارقام سيكون هناك ارتفاع
بعداد الضحايا للاسف طيب منير قلتم في
تصريحات سابقه بانه تاخر وصول المساعدات
سيؤدي لارتفاع اعداد الزلزال في سوريا ما
الذي تنتظرونه كخوض بيضاء وكمنظمه بيضاء
من مساعدات بالتحديد الان وبالدرجه الاولى
لكي تصلكم الى اماكن عمليات الانقاذ
في الحقيقه انا اؤكد هذه المعلومات تاخر
المساعدات سيزيد من عدد الضحايا الساعات
الاولى من اي كارثه هي ساعات مهمه جدا
وصول المساعده في الساعات الاولى مبكره
سوف يكون هناك فرصه كبيره لانتشال عالقين
وهم على قيد الحياه حقيقه نحن نصل الان
الى عوائل تحت الانقاذ فنجد العائله كلها
قد فارقت الحياه باستثناء قد نجد شخص او
او شخص وتكون حالته الصحيه للغايه البرد
الشديد والاصابات والنزيف الذي يعاني منه
المصابين تحت الانقاض هو كفيل بان يفقدوا
ارواحهم الان الاصوات بدات تخف من تحت
الانقاض لم نسمع اصوات الا القليل هناك
حالات قد تكون فقدت الوعي هناك حالات قد
تكون فقدت حياتها تحت الانقاض بسبب التاخر
بالوصول سبب التاخر هو المناشد الذي
اطلقها الالفاظ البيضاء منذ البدايه نحن
نحتاج اليات لرفع هذه الالقاب نحن نحتاج
معدات تقنيه من اجل تساهم بسحب العالقين
وهم احياء من تحت هذه الانقاض الان بدات
القوافل تصل الى المعابر
في في معبر باب الهوى وفي باقي المعابر مع
تركيا في معبر التي هي مع مناطق الشرق
ولكن الان حتى الان هناك اجراءات ضمن هذه
المعابر يعني لم تصل بشكل فعلي الى الى
المستحقين نامل ان يكون اليوم هو يوم
لدخول المساعدات يوم لتخفيف معاناه
المدنيين في شمال غرب سوريا ولكن كفرق بحث
وانقاذ ستساعدنا هذه المساعدات للاسف
بالايشال ضحايا بانتشال الاموات وليس
بانتشال الاحياء لانها تاخرت
طب اليوم كدفاع مدني يا منير وفق خبرتكم
ومعاينتكم لاحداث مشابهه وان لم تكن بهذا
الحجم هل هناك اشخاص قد يكونوا قادرين على
الصمود تحت الانقاض حتى بعد مرور اربعه
ايام من هذه الفاجعه
حقيقه نعم هناك اشخاص قد يستطيعون الصمود
وذلك يتعلق بدرجه الاصابه التي يتعرض لها
هذا الشخص درجه النزيف الذي يتعرض لهذا
الشخص عندما نتحدث انه بعد 72 ساعه يعني
هناك امل ضعيف نعم الامل يصبح ضعيف يعني
الذي يعاني من نزف تحت الانقاذ الذي يعاني
من عمليه هرس تحت الانقاذ هذا الشخص سيكون
معرض بان يفقد حياته بعد هذا الوقت الطويل
هو 72 ساعه يعني ولكن هل هل نفقد الامل
بالكامل عن وجود احياء اكيد اكيد نحن لا
نفقد الامل حتى بعد اسبوع قد يكون هناك
شخص بعد اسبوع
زمني مده زمنيه تقولون يعني هنا سننتهي من
عمليات الانقاذ او تسريع وتيره عمليات
الانقاذ بانه لا امل فقط جثمين وجثث في
نعم نحن نتحدث عن ضعف الامل عن عن ضعف
الذي الذي سيكون هناك ضعف موجود لسحب
ناجين من تحت هذه الانقاض بعض المناطق
عمليا انت انتهينا من سحب الناجين يعني
الذين هم على قيد الحياه وستتحول العمليات
فيها الى سحب جثث من تحت هذه الانقاذ ولكن
نحن لم نفقد الامل في المناطق التي وصلنا
لها ظاهره البارحه حتى الان لن نفقد الامل
بوجود احياء ولكن نحن نتكلم عن تفاعل هذا
تم انقاذه هل اليوم في قصص او حكايات
لاشخاص تم انقاذهم اليوم بالذات
اليوم حتى يعني هذه الساعه التي اتحدث
معكم بها يعني منذ ساعتين حتى الان لم يكن
هناك اي احد موجود يعني تم سحبه على قيد
الحياه ولكن هناك محاولات في اماكن عده
لاصوات تم سماعها من تحت الانقاض ولا زالت
محاولات جاريه ولا زال العمل جاري لسحب
هؤلاء العالقين يعني حتى الان لا يوجد اي
مشاهد اليوم توحي باننا انتشلنا شخص على
قيد الحياه ولكن لا زالت المحاولات جاريه
في بعض الاماكن وخاصه في منطقه جنديرس
وخاصه في منطقه سلقين لا زالت هناك اصوات
سمعناها صباح هذا اليوم يعني باكرا اذا
سمعنا اصوات منذ الساعه الخامسه او
الرابعه صباحا سمعنا اصوات في بعض الاماكن
ولا زادت العمليات تجري بشكل قوي من اجل
ان نستطيع ان نسحبها من تحت هذه الارقام
شكرا جزيلا لك ونذهب مباشره لنستمع الى
المبعوث الامم الى سوريا
قبل موارد نحن بحاجه للمساعدات
ولغات التي يحتاجها المدنيين اينما كانوا
بغض النظر عن الحدود والقيود نحن بحاجه
لها بشكل ملح بسرعه كبيره وعبر وافضل
السبل هذه ما الامور التي يحتاجونها
قبل كل شيء هذه هي الرساله للمجتمع الدولي
ولرساله لكم وللامم المتحده
الاستجابه
للاغاثه يجب ان لا تسيس بل التركيز على ما
يجب تقديمه بشكل سريع لمساعده للمساعده في
انقاذ
المنكوبين وخاصه من بقوا على قيد الحياه
تحت الانقاذ بحاجه الى تصرف سريع للوصول
اليه اليهم بعد 12 من الحرب وتشريد في
سوريا اعتقد ان هذه الكارثه
تاتي
صعبه عليهم وبالتالي يجب ان نتوقف عن
التسيس وان نتدخل بسرعه كبيره شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
كنت اتساءل
باجتماعكم هل هناك اي مؤشر
ان هناك معابر حدوديه اضافيه يمكن فتحها
وما هي المساعدات التي
تقدم لقد تفاجات بالوحده التي رايتها في
اجتماع هذا هذا اليوم
ومن كل الدول التي شاركت بالنسبه
الحدود لدينا مشكله لان هناك طرق دمرت
بسبب الزلزال المؤديه الى تلك المعابر
الحدوديه
ستقدم مساعدات وستدخل اضافيه مساعدات
اضافيه عند اصلاح الطرق
وسنستعمل كل هذه المعابر نحن بحاجه
لمساعده لدخول
الشمال الغربي والى المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها يسيطر عليها النظام وحلب وحمام
وهناك ايضا مساعدات تمر عبر المطار في حلب
وايضا من خلال دمشق
ان الوقت الحالي
لرفع بعض
العقوبات الاحاديه على سوريا سوريا
علينا ان نبدل كل الجهود لضمان عدم وجود
اي
عقبات لوصول المساعدات التي تنقذ الارواح
الى سوريا وقد قد تحدثنا عن هذا مع
مندوبين من الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده واكدوا لي انهم سيبذلوا كل الجهود
الممكنه لضمان عدم وجود اي عقبات امام
المساعده التي توجه الى سوريا للاكمال هذه
العمليه
وان كان هناك اي
عقبات لابد من ابلاغنا كي نتواصل مع
الجهات المعنيه
والتذليل هذه الصعاب
النظام السوري قال انه مستعد للمساعده في
توزيع المساعدات الى المناطق التي لا
يسيطر عليها ما هي الضمانات التي لديكم
منهم على هذا وكيف تم استقبال هذا الامر
من المعارضه والجماعات الاخرى
الماساه في سوريا كبيره
وهي تاتي بعد
12 عاما من الحرب وهناك انقسام المناطق
شمال الغربي ومناطق ايضا يسيطر عليها
النظام هما الاكثر تضررا بالزلزال
نعمل على ضمان عدم وجود اي عقبات سياسيه
لايصال المساعدات
للسكان في المناطق
المنكوبه هذه الرساله يوم امس ورساله لكم
ورساله للسلطات السوريه ولكل طرف معني
بمساعدتنا في الوصول الى المحتاجين
للمساعده
شكرا لكم
ما هذا الاجازه الصحفي المقتضب للمبعوث
الاموي لسوريا جير بادرسن الذي قال بان
الماساه في سوريا كبيره جراء الزلزال هذا
الوصف الذي كرره اكثر من مره المبعوث
المامي لسوريا في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
بدرسا ناشد بالحاجه العاجله للمساعدات
للمتضررين من الزلزال وقال بانه على
الجميع بدل الجهود لعدم اعاقه وصول
المساعدات للسوريين وايضا اكد اكثر من مره
على عدم تسييس الاستجابه للاغاثه في سوريا
فاذا الاستجابه للاغاثه يجب الا تسيس وفق
مقال جيرسن في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
[موسيقى]
الساعه 4:12 دقيقه بلشت الهزه يا دوب
نزلنا من البنايه وصارت الحياطين تهدم
علينا ويا دوب نفذنا بسابع والناس
والله قضينا الليله عند جيراننا بالخيام
بالخيام وغطسنا بالوحل للركب غطشنا يعني
ذبحنا البرد عن جيراننا وما عندهم غطوات
وما بقى السجن نطلع على البنايه نجيب لأنه
حرام
عائلتي نزلت على الدرج هبط عليها بيت
الدرج
ولادي اثنيناتهم بدايه
يعني ايش بدي اقول لك والله ما اعرف بعد
ما اطلعنا
ينفتح ولا اخر شيء شو صاروا
نزل البيت كلياته والله سلمنا الحمد لله
شاب سوري يدعم محمد الصواف انتشر له تسجيل
صوتي وهو يستغيث طلبا لانقاذه لحسن الحظ
ان فرق الانقاذ استطاعت اخراجه سليما من
تحت الانقاض ولكن من دون اخيه ساري الصواف
الذي خرج من تحت الانقاض جثه هامده
الحمدلله
على السلامه
[موسيقى]
الصبر يا رب الصبر بس والله عم توجعك ايدك
لا تحرك ايدك انت
ما بتوجعني
اه طبعا نشير بان السعوديه كانت اطلقت
حمله عبر منصه ساهم الالكترونيه
ولاقت استجابه كبيره منذ الساعات الاولى
لطرحها حيث تتلقى دعما ايضا ومعونات
لايصالها بعد ذلك من خلال الجسر الجوي
السعودي الى مناطق المتضررين حيث وصلت
طائره الجسر الجوي السعودي الى اضنه
لتوزيع المساعدات وايضا فرق الانقاذ التي
تساهم في عمليات الانقاذ الى هذه الصور
التي اظهرتها الاقمار الصناعيه نشرت حجم
الدمار الذي لحق بمناطق واسعه جنوبي تركيا
وذلك من خلال عمل مقارنات بين صور العمران
والبناء السكاني قبل وبعد زلزال المدمر
[موسيقى]
دعونا نذهب معكم الى الحدود التركيه
السوريه ينضم الينا من هناك الصحه في
ابراهيم الادلبي ابراهيم مرحبا بك معنا في
سياق هذه التغطيه اخر المعلومات كيف يبدو
الوضع لديكم اهلا وسهلا بك وبجميع
المشاهدين بدايه دعيني ابدا من تبعيات
الكارثه واثارها حيث ان هناك ارتفاع في
منسوب نهر العاصي في المنطقه الغربيه من
ادلب اتحدث عن منطقه التلول وايضا عن بعض
القرى المحيطه فيها وايضا مدينه سلقين هذا
الارتفاع النسبي للمياه ادى الى تضرر عدد
من المنازل والاحياء وهناك قرابه السبعه
الاف مدني اضطر للتحرك من منطقه التلول
والقرى المحيطه بنهر العاصي باتجاه
المناطق الشماليه مع الحدود السوريه
التركيه لان ارتفاع هذا المنسوب قد ينجر
ايضا
دمار الابنيه المتصدعه التي
زلزال الجيولوجيه تتوالى وتتداعى نعم ما
تزال هذه التبعيات حتى هذه اللحظه نت
كوارث نتحدث عن ارتفاع منسوب نهر العاصي
هناك بعض المخيمات المنتشره على ضفاف نهر
العاصي بريف ادلب الغربي في محيط جسر
الشغور او المناطق التي يعبر منها هذا
النهر او وصولا الى مدينه سلقين التي ايضا
غمرت بعض شوارعها بالمياه وهناك تخوف من
زياده ارتفاع منسوب المياه في تلك المنطقه
مما اضطر الاهالي للاتجاه باتجاه مناطق
اكثر امنا وهي الحدود السوريه التركيه
طيب هو ابراهيم اليوم ما زالت حتى هذه
الساعه المعلومات متضاربه حول وضع المعابر
على الحدود التركيه السوريه يعني تاره
نسمع بانها لا تعمل وغير مفعله وتاره نسمع
بانها تنقل جثميين فقط لدفنهم من سوريا ان
تنقلهم للجانب التركي الى السوري ما حقيقه
ما يجري حتى الساعه
المعابر هي على اوبه الاستعداد من الطرف
السوري من اجل استقبال
المساعدات او استقبال الجسامين من الطرف
التي تاتي من الطرف التركي بالمقابل
المساعدات الدوليه او المساعدات من الجانب
السوري الاستعدادات كامله وكافيه عن
التعطيل من الجانب التركي
اليس هناك
تعطيل
ما بين المساعدات الاغاثيه كمطار اضنه
الذي يجب العبور من مدينه انطاكيا
والمدينه شبه مدمره وبعض الطرق السريعه
خرجت عن الخدمه هناك محاوله للالتفاف على
هذه الطرق لادخال المساعدات كما تفضلوا
المراسلكم شبكه مراسلكم تحدثوا عن تجهيز
قوافل ضمن المطارات التي حطت بها
المساعدات الدوليه توجهها الى شمال غرب
سوريا ولكن حتى الان هذه المساعدات لن تصل
الى المعبر من الجانب التركي عند وصولها
الى المعبر من الجانب التركي ستكون الامور
اكثر ثلاثه للدخول والمعابر التي اعلنت
استعدادها هي كمعبر باب الهوى الذي اصدر
بيانيا متزامنين عن استعداد واستعداد
طواقمه لاستقبال السيارات سيارات الاغاثه
الدوليه من اجل نقلها الى الداخل السوري
وتوزيعها برفقه كل الجهات يعني حتى نتصور
ونتخيل اكثر لمن لا يعرف الجغرافيا في
خصوصا في بين هذين البلدين اليوم اذا ما
افترض انه في قافله مساعدات تاتي من
الجانب التركي واذا استبعدنا باب الهوى
بسبب الطرق التي تضررت لمعبر باب الهوى
بفعل الزلزال السلام والراعي كم المده
الزمنيه التي تستغرق الكيلومترات مثلا لكي
نصل الى اقرب نقطه من الجانب التركي الى
سوريا
بقيت في مطار اضنه او في مطار انطاكيا
وتريد هذه المساعده الوصول الى المعبرين
الذين ذكرتوهما معبر باب السلامه ومعبر
الراعي سيكون الامر شبه مستحيل في هذه
الاثناء ولكن في كان في حال كانت
المساعدات موجوده في مطار غازي عنتاب الذي
تم اعاده من اجل استقبال المساعدات
سيستغرق الامر بعد تجهيز القوافل
وانطلاقها قرابه الثلاث ساعات للوصول الى
المعبرين معا الى معبر باب السلامه في ريف
حلب بالقرب من عزاز او حتى معبر الراعي
ايضا في ريف حلب بعد دخولها من الراعي او
حتى من باب السلامه ستحتاج ايضا الى قرابه
الاربع ساعات حتى تصل الى المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا اتحدث الى اريف
ادلب او الى اقرب منطقه في ريف ادلب هي
منطقه اطمه على على بالنسبه لريف حلب اذا
نحن نتحدث
عن يوم اضافي حتى تصل مثلا على نخرج جدلا
ان تصل المساعدات الى المتضررين
[موسيقى]
نتحدث عن الريف حلب عن منطقه ريف عفرين
اليوم هي ايضا من المناطق الاكثر تضررا
وذلك بسبب الابنيه العمرانيه التي كانت
منشاه منذ عشرات السنوات والتي لم تعتمد
على اكواد البناء الخاصه بالزلازل وخاصه
ان سوريا في وقت سابق لم تكن هي منطقه خطر
او منطقه زلازل نشطه لذلك كان هناك تضرر
كبير جدا في الارياف اكثر من المدن نتحدث
عن جنديرس التي دمرت بنسبه 80% سويت على
الارض ونشاهد الجميع ويشاهد الجميع ما
يحدث في مدينه جنديرس عمليات الانقاذ ما
تزال متواصله منذ بدايه الزلزال حتى هذه
اللحظات يحاول تحاول فرق الدفاع المدني
والمدني المتطوعين والقوى المختصه بانتشال
الجسد او البحث عن مصابين تاتي في المرتبه
الثانيه ريف ادلب الغربي ايضا منطقه سهليه
بالبناء الذي كان فيها غير مهيا لاستقبال
الزلازل والصدمات بالاض من المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه على مدار السنوات
الماضيه تعرضت للكثير من عمليات القصف مما
ادى الى تصدع هذه المباني ساهم الزلزال
والهزات الارتداديه
بتدمير اكبر عدد ممكن من الابنيه وتشريد
المدنيين نتحدث عن عشرات الالاف من
المدنيين ممن اباتوا في الثلاث ايام
الماضيه ثلاث ليالي الماضيه في العراق
وذلك خشيه من العوده الى المباني المتصدعه
او لانهم فقدوا منازلهم جراء الهزات
الارضيه والهزات الارتداديه جل التركيز
اليوم على كافه المناطق التي تحتاج الى
مساعده كيف يتم تقييم المناطق الاكثر
احتياجا الى مساعده بناء على بلاغات من
قبل المدنيين او شهود العيان الذين لديهم
تاكيدات انه ما يزال تحت الانقاض عالقون
على قيد الحياه او ان الابنيه كان فيها
مدنيون قبل ان تنهار لان نتحدث عن ابنيه
مدمره او ابنيه مدمره في عموم المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه القوى الموجوده وفرق
الدفاع المد لا تستطيع بشكل عام تغطيه
كافه المناطق لذلك اعتمدوا على البلاغات
المؤكده لوجود مدنيين ضمن الابنيه التي
دمرت خاصه ان هناك بعض المدنيين او
المدنيين الذين حلفهم الحزب الخروج من
مبنيهم قبل ان تنهار لذلك هناك محاوله
للحصول على تاكيدات بالمرحله الاولى لوجود
ناجين المرحله الثانيه لوجود مدنيين كانوا
قد علقوا تحت الانقاب في فتره الزلزال
والهزات الارتداديه ابراهيم ابقى معنا في
سياق هذه التغطيه نذهب من الحدود السوريه
التركيه الى من مدينه جنديرس بريف حلب من
اكثر المدن تضررا وينضم الينا معنا من
هناك صحفي محمد الاشقر محمد اهلا بك معنا
في ريف حلب اذا مصنفه كاكثر المناطق تضررا
فكيف لنا ان نتصور حجم الدمار والماسات
لديكم تفضل
نعم يعني في الحقيقه نحن الان في احد
الاحياء التي المدمره بفعل الكارثه الكبرى
التي حدثت في المنطقه نتيجه الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا نحن الان
تحديدا في حي سوق الهال هذا الحي الذي
يظهر امامكم على الشاي من تحت الانقاض
سواء اكانوا جثامين لحالات وفاه او حتى لا
يزال الجميع هنا يعمل على امل تحقيق
المعجزه واخراج
ناجين من تحت الانقاذ رغم صعوبه
وعدم احتماليه وجود ناجين الى حد هذه
اللحظه خصوصا بعد مرور اربعه ايام عن عن
هذه
الكارثه طبعا لم تتوقف عمليات الانقاذ هنا
في مدينه جنديرس الصوره ابلغ من اي كلام
الصوره وحدها تتحدث فرق الدفاع المدني ما
زالت مستمره بمسانده الاهالي وبع الجهات
المختصه للتعامل مع مثل هذه الكوارث جميع
الاهالي هنا يعيشون على امل خروج ذويهم من
تحت الانقاض وهم
احياء الى حد هذه اللحظه لا يخرج الا
الجثث
وجثامين حالات الوفاه من تحت الانقاض
للاسف الى حد هذه اللحظه لم نسجل في هذا
اليوم خروج اي حاله قد نجت من تحت الالقاب
ايضا مكنت من اخراج جثمان جثه جديده من
احد
المباني الى احد هذه اللحظه اعيد واكرر
لم تتمكن فرق الدفاع في هذا اليوم من
انقاذ اي حاله جديده بقيت على قيد الحياه
في الحقيقه منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر ونحن
هنا في هذا الحي عشرات الجثامين خرجت من
تحت الانقاض ان سمحت لي تحدث عن هذا
البناء الذي وصلنا اليه وكانت الدفاع فرق
الدفاع المدني قد تقريبا قد انتهت من
اخراج الضحايا من تحت الانقاض وكان عند
وصولنا تمكنوا من اخراج اخر ثمانيه جثامين
لاخر ثمانيه حالات وفاه في هذا المبنى
القريب من عدسه الكاميرا المبنى الذي خلفه
والذي لا تزال فرق الدفاع المدني تعمل على
انتشال الضحايا من تحت الانقاض ايضا تحت
الانقاذ لا يزال هناك عشرات
الضحايا تحت الانقاض الى حد هذه اللحظه لم
تتمكن فرق الدفاع المدني من انقاذ من
اخراج سوى خمسه جثامين من هذا المبنى
وايضا المباني الاخرى لم تخرج منها الا
جثامين لحالات وفاه سقطت
خصوصا بعد طول الزمن نحن هنا نتحدث عن
اربعه ايام
قضاها تحت
تحدثنا الى خبير في عمليات الانقاذ قال
بكل صراحه للاسف احتماليه خروج احد من تحت
الانقاض بعد اربعه ايام من حدوث الكارثه
هي احتماليه ضعيفه جدا وتحتاج لمعجزه ولكن
اهالي واقرباء الضحايا الذين لا يزالون
تحت الانقاض يعيشون على حاله الامل يعيشون
حاله ترقب على امل ان يخرج ذويهم
وهم على قيد الحياه وعلى ان تتمكن فرق
الدفاع المدني من انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من
تحت هذه الانقاض يعني وعلى امل الوصول الى
معجزه وان يكون الامل وبقعه الضوء من بين
الظلام الركام الذي يغطي رؤوس المواطنين
حيث سقطت هذه الابنيه يعني فعلا محمد هذه
المشاهد وهذا النقل المباشر لح سوق الهال
في جنديرس كفيله وكافيه لكي تصف لنا الوضع
الماساوي المؤلم خصوصا في هذه المنطقه
اكثر المناطق تضررا في ريف حلب يعني محمد
نتابع معك هذا الحي مدمر بالكامل يعني
اصبح حي مهجور حتى هذه اللحظه هل تفضل
محمد
نعم طبعا ان اتحدث ان اشير الى نقطه مهمه
الى ان الصوره ابلغ من اي حديث ابلغ من اي
صحفي
تعجز الكلمات عن وصف الحاله والكارثه هنا
في مدينه جنديرس المدينه اغلب احياء
المدينه هي شبيهه بهذا الحي المدينه
منكوبه بكل ما تعنيه كلمه منكوبه من معنى
حجم الكارثه هنا في مدينه جنديرس هو اكبر
بكثير من قدرات فرق الدفاع المدني هو اكبر
بكثير من قدرات الشبان هو اكبر بكثير من
قدرات الفرق التطوعيه ولكن الجميع هنا
يعمل باعلى طاقاته الجميع يعمل بل اكثر من
طاقاته محاولا انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من
تحت الانقاض الجميع يعيش حاله الامل
الى حد هذه اللحظه تصل فرق انقاذ جديده
الى مدينه جنديرس باعتبارها احدى المناطق
التي تعرضت للكارثه محاولين جميعهم انقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه والى حد هذه اللحظه لا
تزال عمليات الانقاذ مستمره في اغلب احياء
مدينه جنديرس التي صنفت بحسب ناشطين بانها
منكوبه طبعا حاولنا في مدينه جنديرس
التواصل مع فرق الانقاذ وفرق الدفاع
المدني للحصول على احصائيه تقريبيه فقط في
مدينه جنديرس ولكن للاسف لم نتمكن من
الوصول الى رقم
الى رقم
يمثل احصائيه لعدد الضحايا هنا في مدينه
جنديرس وذلك بسبب عدد المباني التي تدمرت
بشكل كامل بسبب انتشارها على كامل احياء
المدينه بسبب
وجود عشرات بالمئات من الضحايا في هذه
المدينه سبب طبعا سبب ارتفاع الضحايا هنا
هو بسبب وجود مهجرين قد هجروا سابقا من
قبل نظام النظام السوري باتجاه هذه
المدينه ولجاوا اليها ولكنهم الان باتوا
تحت انقاض هذه المدينه منهم من من من من
توفي تحت الانقاض مباشره ومنهم من عانى
لوقت طويل وهو ينتظر فرق الانقاذ لتنقذه
ولكن لم تتمكن هذه الفرق من انقاذه طبعا
ضعف الامكانيات ضعف المعدات ضعف المواد
والمعدات اللوجستيه المجهزه واللازمه
للتعامل مع مثل هذه الكوارث حاله دون رفع
رفع نسبه
الانقاذ ونسبه الناجين وانخفاض حالات
الوفيات هذا الامر انعدام المعدات وانعدام
التجهيزات اللوجستيه اللازمه تسبب للاسف
بارتفاع الوفيات وانخفاض الحالات التي
تمكنت فرق الدفاع المدني وفرق الانقاذ من
انقاذها من تحت الانقاض يعني اعيد واكرر
هنا مدينه جنديرس في ريف حلب مدينه منكوبه
مدينه غير صالحه للسكن عشرات بالمئات
المباني تعرضت للدمار الكلي ومئات المباني
او ما تبقى من المباني تعرض
للدمار الجزئي وهو غير صالح للسكن يعني في
الحقيقه الاهالي الذين لا زالوا يسكنون
بمنازلهم رغم انها تصدعت نتيجه
الزلزال او حتى الهزات الارتداديه بسبب
عدم وجود اي مكان يلجا اليه السؤال الذي
يخطر في بالهم دائما والسؤال الذي نسال هو
عن احتماليه حدوث زلزال اخر او هزات
ارتداديه شديده قد تتسبب بانهيار هذه
المنازل التي التي يسكنوها فوق رؤوسهم
حاله خوف وحاله هلع هنا تسيطر على الاهالي
الذين بقيوا منهم من نجى من اهالي جنديرس
وكتبت له الحياه مجددا اين رحلوا اين
يعيشون الان ما هو وضعهم
نعم ان تحدثنا عن هذا الجانب الجانب
الانساني وحاله الناجين طبعا الناجين قد
توزعوا باتجاه مناطق عده باتجاه مراكز
ايواء مؤقته كانت قد قد
اسستها وانشاتها الفرق التطوعيه والمنظمات
الانسانيه في مختلف
مناطق ريف حلب الشمالي او حتى ريف ادلب
طبعا هذا هؤلاء الناجون يعانون من حاله
انسانيه صعبه
نتيجه
احتياجاتهم للمواد الغذائيه
والمواد التدفئه وحتى المياه وايضا للمواد
الطبيه الجميع يعلم ان هذه الكارثه حدثت
في فصل الشتاء الامر الذي فاقم هذه
الكارثه وجعل
انعكاساتها على على الاهالي
مضاعفه اكثر واكثر طبعا المساعدات التي
تقدم لهؤلاء الاهالي الناجين هي مساعدات
تقدم بجهود شعبيه محليه هي تقدم بجهود من
قبل المنظمات الانسانيه المحليه من خلال
مستودعاتها الموجوده سابقا في المنطقه
وايضا من خلال الفرق التطوعيه ولكن النسبه
الاكبر التي تقدم
الناجين هنا للفرق الانقاذ من ناحيه
المواد الغذائيه الطعام والشراب هي من قبل
الشعب السوري الذي قرر ان يتكافل مع بعضه
البعض ليواجه هذه الكارثه وهو في الحقيقه
الامر الذي ساهم ولو بشكل جزئي في مواجهه
هذه الكارثه حاله التكاتف الشعبي التي
شهدتها مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
خففت نوعا ما من من من من الصدمه التي
تعرضت لها الفرق المختصه فرق الدفاع
المدني
وحيده لو تركت وحيده لكانت الكارثه اكبر
مع ان الجميع عمل باقصى طاقاته الان انتم
تشاهدون على الشاشه ايضا وصول فريق انقاذ
جديد الى المنطقه طبعا الجميع هنا يعمل
سبق وان تحدثنا عن هذه النقطه الجميع يعمل
باعلى من طاقاته باكبر من طاقته
نحن كنا بحاجه هنا في الشمال السوري فرق
الانقاذ كانت بحاجه معدات وتجهيزات واليات
مجهزه
ومساعده للتعامل مع مثل هذه الكوارث ولكن
انعدامها وعدم وفرتها وعدم دخولها في
الوقت المناسب تسبب بارتفاع حالات الوفيات
وانخفاض حالات الناجين الذين قد تمكنت فرق
الانقاذ من انقاذهم ومحمد بالتاكيد يعني
ليس فقط الخوف من الزلزال لحظه وقوع لكن
لنا ان نتخيل من علقوا بين الركام وسقطت
الابنيه فوق رؤوسهم لنا ان نتخيل كيف
يعيشون تحت هذا الركام وتحت هذا الحطام في
الظلام وفي حاله في الخوف وفي حاله من
التساؤلات يعني كم من المده التي ساعيش
فيها او استطيع الصمود فبالتالي يعني
مشاهد مخيفه سواء لحظه وقوع الزلزال وحتى
ما تلا ذلك اليوم محمد يعني وانا اشاهد
هذه المشاهد يعني الان اصبح الجميع بحاله
الصمت وذهول ونحن نستمع لك ونشاهد هذه
الصور مباشره من سوق الهال في جنديرس اكثر
المناطق تضرا يدفعنا الى التساؤل خصوصا
وان المؤشرات والمعطيات لا تشي بان قد
يكون حياه على هذه المناطق وفي هذه
المناطق في المستقبل القريب في الاشهر او
حتى السنين المقبله بالتالي هل سوريا
ستعيش حاله نزوح جديده من نوع اخر
[موسيقى]
نعم يعني في الحقيقه هذه المنطقه هي بحاجه
لاعاده اعمار مثلها مثل باقي المناطق التي
تدمرت بفعل قصف
روسيا والنظام السوري الاهالي هم نزحوا
اساسا منذ اربعه ايام ولجاوا الى اماكن
متفرقه نحن في الحقيقه نعيش امام كارثه
انسانيه يعاني منها هؤلاء الناجون من
المدن التي تعرضت
للدمار بفعل الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
المنطقه نعم هناك حاله نزوح جديده حاله
هجره جديده للاهالي المهجرين اساسا باتجاه
هذه القرى طبعا مدينه جنديرس ان تحدثنا عن
هذه المدينه لجا اليها الكثير من اهالي من
اهالي حمص وغوطه دمشق وحلب التي هجروا
بفعل قوات النظام السوري وقوات روسيا الان
هجروا مجددا من تمكن من النجاه من تحت
الانقاض وتمكن من النجاه بنفسه من هذا
الزلزال قد هجر مجددا قد نزح مجددا باتجاه
مناطق اخرى اغلبهم الى الان يقطن تحت
اشجار الزيتون في مراكز سعيد الحظي منهم
اساسا من وجد مركز ايواء يحويه مع عائلته
مع اطفال سنكون معك
الشيخ ابيه ان وجد نعم وسنعود اليكم بعد
قليل شكرا جزيلا لكم حتى هذه اللحظه محمد
الاشقر من جنديرس في ريف حلب واشكر ايضا
ضيفنا من الحدود سوريه التركيه ابراهيم
الادلبي الصحفي من هناك شكرا لكما
التغطيه طبعا مستمره على العربيه وكنا
معكم منذ اليوم الاول ومنذ اللحظات الاولى
والساعات الاولى لوقوع هذا الزلزال الذي
ما زالت تداعياته تضرب اكثر من الضربه
التي اوقعتها الهزه الجيولوجيه التغطيه
مستمره على العربيه الى اللقاء